One of the ways that you bonded was through
martial arts and you all trained together.
You've obviously, I mean, you played Muhammad Ali,
so you've been in many roles where you've had to be
very physical.
You've been down this road before.
But you all had to train pretty serious, is that true?
Yeah.
David takes that really seriously.
David is one of the best directors
that I've ever worked with.
I mean, he a little crazy.
He a little crazy but you can't take that
away from him, ya know what I mean?
It's like David, he knows how to get inside of a human mind,
ya know, and like stir it all up,
and then say action.
'Cause you think you're bonding and you're being friends
and you're telling 'em all your darkest secrets
and we're all spending time together.
We start telling our secrets and we're opening up
and then, Dave is like, "Yeah, yeah, yeah."
Then one day on the set, he's like,
"Yo dude, she's that girl that cheated on you
"in eighth grade."
(laughing)
Action.
That's a good way to get it done.
(gasp)
(laughing)
Another way, you guys bonded over music too?
Is that right?
I mean, music's important to you.
Music's important.
You like the cast to listen to certain songs.
Yeah, I gave Noomi some music to listen to
and I think I gave you some stuff.
It just, I mean there's real soul to music
and when I direct, there'll be songs or playlists
I can kinda listen to that gets me inspired.
I was listening to pretty dark stuff that you sent me.
Yeah, pretty dark character.
Give me an example of a song that you guys
bonded over that was really out there.
Well so, the songs I was playing was not
the songs he's gonna pick.
I had this song, I love this song called Heels On
and I was playing it kind of in my corner
of the makeup trailer a lot.
Kind of quite low because it's quite sexual.
It's like Jamaican, it's a beautiful black woman singing.
She's called Lady Saw.
It's very full on, so I was like one day,
it was like,
Will was on the other side.
Let me just ask you.
What is Heels On?
Just act like I don't know.
What are you talking about?
So one day, Will was like, "Can you turn that up?"
I was like, "Should I?"
She sings like, "I'm gonna (beep) you with my heels on."
(audience cheering)
(applause)
Noomi's playlist, Noomi listens to rap music
that black people'd be like, "Nah, nah."
(laughing)
True, it's so true.
That is vulgar,
turn that off!
Hardcore.
That's really upsetting.
Snoop be like, "Nah, we can't listen to that."
(laughing)